what advice would you give to your past
self when you're just entering the
equipment industry the advice i'd give
would definitely be to have belief in
the people around you they've been there
seen them and done it and they know if
you're doing the right things or not and
it's really tough to see
how you're going to be successful before
you get successful but if the people
around you have been there and done it
then just trust that they know you're
going in the right direction
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
my first commission paycheck uh came
through at midnight when i was in ibiza
oh wow and uh so i came away with
nothing to show for it but i had a good
time
love that what non-negotiable do you
live by each day that you feel has a
massive impact on your productivity
getting up at 5am and planning my day
they're the key things i think what are
the top three things i need to do every
day and getting up at the same time
every day they're the most important
things for me how do you think we can
really go about changing the perception
of the industry i think the perception
of recruitment industry has to change
but i think that the days when you used
to be able to take clients out and get
them drunk and that was how you
submitted relationships i think they've
gone um at least they've they've
minimized because people aren't around
as often in the city or in in the
offices in that so how do you get in
front of people so it's not about by you
know taking them out for good times
about adding value presenting data
sharing information that they need to
make their jobs easier so i think with
that in mind the perception of the
recruitment industry will change because
it's not about the wide boys and the
gift of the gab anymore it's about
adding real value
well
now that bro cheers mate nice one thanks
a lot mate pleasure
you